out of respect and out of
exaltation for the messenger of
Allah Those are the ones whom
Allah has prepared and found
suitable their hearts for a
taqwa. For righteousness. For
those individuals, for them is
a forgiveness, And a general
forgiveness and a great reward.
In this verse, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala mentions those who
lower their voices in the
presence of the prophet
and what is meant by lowering
their voices in the presence of
the prophet obviously in his
lifetime, in his presence
physically. And that is out of
respect for him. However, after
he has passed away, how is it
that we may attain this reward?
Well, the spirit of the verse
is at a person tailor behavior
that a person tailor his
behavior
exalt the prophet and that can
be because he is physically
there. Because a person is to
and be could be because the
prophet is physically there and
the person is is wishing to
articulate his
his
good manners and his
exaltation of him to him or
that a person is respectful to
the of the prophet and also the
people the son of the prophet
those who are
carriers of that sunnah, those
who are scholars of that
sunnah. and so,
exalt thee companions of the
prophet not because of their
inherent being but because of
their position to the prophet
Muhammad likewise, those who
are most acquainted and most
closely follow the prophet
he says in the following verse,
indeed those who call to you
from behind the walls of your
rooms, the majority of them do
not understand end. Meaning,
they do not understand properly
how they are too conduct
themselves with the prophet and
these verses were revealed
regarding an incident in which
the prophet was sleeping and
some people came to see him and
they started to yell for him
from behind the walls of his
wives homes. And he came out to
them and obviously this was an
inappropriate way to
This was an inappropriate way
to initiate their contact with
the prophet
Allah then says in the fifth
verse and if they had only been
patient and waited for you to
come out to to meet them, it
would have been better for
them. Better for them, We know
that it was bad that they
called to the prophet in this
way. So, how can this be
better? Because the word better
articulates that that was good
but this is better. That's
sometimes what it means in the
Quran but often times, the word
better in the Quran can be the
opposite and mean the opposite
of that which is bad. So, Allah
will mention the people of the
Hellfire and then say the
people of paradise are any
better position. Doesn't mean
that the people of hell are in
a good position and the people
of paradise are in a better
position. It means that better
here in this context is the
opposite of that which is
worse, right? So, he says and
if they had only been patient
until you had emerged to meet
them, that would have been
better for them. Meaning, that
would have been the correct
course of action. And Allah is
off forgiving, most merciful.
Meaning, in spite of people and
their the distress they cause
others and the lack of empathy
that people have and
inappropriate behavior that
people often have. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala overlooks a
lot of this and we understand
from this that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala's when he holds
someone to account. When he
holds someone to account for
what they've done, It's very
deliberate. It's very deliber
it and there is absolutely no
excuse this person can have.
There is no such thing in front
of Allah as I didn't know.
There is no such thing as I
didn't think so. A person once
they have been reprimanded by
Allah At that point, everyone
and at the top of those people,
the person being reprimanded
himself, all agree that it was
long overdue And so, the
essential nature of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is one of
pardoning, one of forgiveness,
one of mercy.